question is
lex i was wondering if you would be
willing to talk about your immigrant
experience
i myself started off as an international
student studying and working in america
not from russia i'm from india but there
was
a constant push and pull that i
experienced given my life circumstance
i would be curious to hear how you
assimilated
do you feel like you belong etc thank
you for the ama
okay your statement's about do you feel
like you belong hit hard for some reason
maybe it's because late at night maybe
because i'm
a bit over caffeinated maybe what pops
to mind
to focus on is the aspect of
loneliness the aspect of belonging i
think
a lot of us in the early teenage years
go through that process of
feeling like an outsider an outcast of
different kinds
i think it hit me the hardest personally
because
i was a popular kid in russia and when
we moved here
i went to the opposite of being popular
or
feeling like that i felt like an outcast
the the place i moved to in america had
more of an emphasis maybe it's a
cultural thing
of uh emphasizing material possessions
over two things that
were deeply meaningful to me which is
human connection like friendship
and also knowledge like
mathematics and scientific discovery all
those kinds of things
it's just the emphasis of what was
valued was different
and that for me was a catalyst to feel
like a total outcast
as opposed to being this person who
looks out into the world and enjoys
the beauty of the world i kind of went
to this brooding
phase of first of all learning the
english language but
starting to read books more
philosophical books
the first one i remember reading in
english was the giver
that sort of helped me start thinking
about this world
i was so fortunate to be so in love with
people
for so long and have close friends in in
russia
that i didn't notice in my childhood
how deeply alone we all are
so for me the immigrant experience
involved in a small way at least the
first
realizing that hard human truth that
we all are born alone
live alone die alone even when we're in
the
arms of somebody we love we're still
somehow fundamentally alone
with our thoughts with our hopes with
our
fears trapped in this uh
conscious meat vessel between our ears
i think the immigrant experience for me
was the catalyst to
realizing and being
terrified and also liberated by the idea
that um
i'm alone in this world and
at the same time was the realization
that this beautiful feeling i felt
from the connection to other humans
was this gift that
uh took me away from this dark
realization
so it's almost that love is kind of
escape from the reality
of life from the muck of life
and so the journey began in that way to
think about this world in this way
both the burden of being alone coupled
with a frequent escape from that feeling
by being lost in the company of
friends loved ones so early on coupled
with this
love of the human mind and curiosity
about the human mind
was the love of programming and actually
building little programs
and engineering systems of course
building robots in college and so on
i think the gift of the immigrant
experience of feeling like the outcast
was the love of
experiencing the deep connection with
others
like a deep appreciation of it when it's
there i guess because it was taken away
because i was ripped out of it
through moving here i got to really
appreciate it
and start becoming cognizant of it to
where i can start looking for it
and being more grateful when i do have
it and at the same
time a kind of curiosity started boiling
up of
the perspective on artificial
intelligence systems
from that kind of longing for a
connection so
as opposed to looking at robots or ai
systems or
even just programs that accomplish a
particular task
can these programs accomplish the same
richness
of task and richness of experience that
i came to appreciate as a human being
you know so when i talk about kind of
love
it's there's echoes of that in my
longing of the kind of experiences i
would like to create
in artificial intelligence systems that
was born
out of the immigrant experience
of the loss of
child-like innocence experience of all
of it combined
of starting to read books and thinking
deeply about this world experience all
that coupled in
i really think sometimes unfortunately
the first step of deep gratitude
is loss so for me i lost quite a bit
during that time
and through that loss i was able to
discover the things
that i truly appreciate about life so
let me leave it at that
you